sur la question vous posé par rapport à
la à la période contemporaine
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à cette
question là en voilà en voyant surgir
partout lâche tags
on n'oubliera pas que j'ai traduit mois
par vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir gens il ya des comptes qui vont se
payer et des comptes qui vont se régler
et je suis tombé sur un article de l'ops
qui est assez récent et qui reprenait
les travaux de l'historien jean delumeau
qui disait qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de constantes qu'on voyait dans
chaque situation d'épidémie
il a écrit ce en 1978 et à deux
constantes qui sont relevés la défiance
envers les autorités et la recherche des
coupables
et là on est en train d'observer un
certain rapprochement qui s'opère entre
ces deux choses là et également avec le
fait qu'ils aient une espèce d'inflation
de procédure et que de nos jours bat
j'observe ça avec un oeil un petit peu
ironique voire carrément sarcastique ont
plein pour tout et pour rien et il ya
des gens qui sont absolument
remarquables qui sont capables avec une
une persévérance quasiment bretonne de
poursuivre jusqu'à la cour de cassation
pour des choses mais qu'ils sont mais
minuscule l'un des derniers exemples
j'avais commenté ça sur mon blog
un des derniers exemples c'est un
parieur qui a estimé qu'ils avaient
check-list et un hors jeu ou un coup
franc qui avaient été sifflées ou qui
n'avait pas été sifflé et qui disait à
cause de ça
le match était perdu et donc à la
française des jeux vous me devez 150000
euros et la pousse et ça quand même
jusqu'à la cour de cassation
moi je dis bravo et je pense qu'il ya un
certain nombre de personnes jeudi avec
un peu d'humour si vous voulez qui
risque peut-être de mal passer sur le
sujet qui est le nôtre mais il ya un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont le
couteau judiciaire entre les dents qui
sont prêts à aller effectivement à
l'affrontement judiciaire alors que
peut-être sur un certain nombre de
points mais en tout cas je suis
sceptique sur le fait que ce soit un
recevable et deux fondés sur le plan
rigoureusement juridique
[Musique]